hi again so we're going to continue with
the team about the memorable losses or
painful loss is how you call your and
they're never pleasant but this hope to
learn well one thing is sure the more
you can get closer to the end of your
career you have more more of these
losses so this is like a clear sign so
I'm not surprised today just like up
over hours ago I have read that chronic
has announced that this will be his last
tournament at least his last serious
tournament well although they say that
you can play chess you know almost all
your life but array your strength is not
the same so the moment in my opinion you
reach around between 35 and 40 you don't
have the same energy and you start
making more mistakes so it's about if
you've played many tournaments like for
example I have played your nervous
system maybe is not the same so there
are a lot of components which influence
your game and I've here shows some games
just at the end of my chest career no
this actually was meant to be the last
tournament I had intention to play this
was the 78th the Bulgaria individual
championship there was almost all of the
bests just past well except the actual
champion listening to power but he
didn't play for many many years and most
of the best players decide to place them
there were decent conditions and
although I bill turned out to be the
last tournament but away after that I
didn't play for more than three years
enough that I just played just for fun
but the way this was actually the the
one term I considered that in the last
one and in this particular tournament I
lost three games well the first one was
actually in the second round against a
very famous grandmasters of our skier
George if oh by chance we went we went
with him together in the in the melee
but all right this game was not so
interesting but also was a good sign
that what I was what's waiting for me
during turn because I was making some
quite unpleasant mistakes in the
calculation I was spending more time
than usual but especially the two games
I've chosen to show you today we had a
lot of memories for me and not because
in one of them like the first one I had
good chances and if I have who want this
game maybe starting from this one I
could have won even the the next three
games - and I've got two and a half
instead of four out of four by the way
this is quite easy to explain having in
mind that you're not playing like you
used to play and the second one is also
quite interesting laws because I think
that I have to give credit to my
opponent he played very well and he's
the kind of loss well you can try to
find where you may have played better
where I use a mistake but the truth is
my opponent played almost perfectly and
he found over the brought an incredible
novelty by the way let me first show you
the first game and then we'll take a
look at the second one or the first game
was played against maybe this time he
was already a grandmaster I used to play
one game with him in the open Bulgaria
championship some years ago I even won
two of this championship in row and I
wouldn't like a good game against him
with black so I felt quite comfortable
in this game and I was aiming to have
like a good fighting position with both
results on the broad this is like a term
you'll hear me use quite often but this
is what I like when I choose my opener
Goethe to have like positions with the
three results possible on the broad I
don't like to play some kind of a more
passive opening lines which may be solid
and which may be more appropriate for
the top level tournaments but when you
play in a lot of open tournaments you
you get a heavier chances and it doesn't
matter if you play with white or black
you gotta have like fighting position so
he played see for and against c4 I have
very often played a 5 and in most of the
games you have either the reverse dragon
or either you have all kind of position
like the reverse sicilians and why I
chose this opening well
because I like doing all of my chest
Korea and I have developed this chest
taste of course that I have played all
kinds of openings but when I came
experience almost all of the openings
you tend to know yourself much better
over the chest broad so I prefer
position with a good space control so I
like to play like more central opening
lines and especially opening lines when
I have space so here I play e5 and
sometimes depending of the opponents I
can play Knight f6 and if he plays
Knight e3 then I can play
Nephi's of course I have played knight
of Cygnus 3e 6e foreign different lines
but especially this opponent I didn't
have any doubt that he'll try to play
like more flexible and maybe to keep the
knight on b1 maybe to play against the
reverse dragon with a knight in d2 so I
played a 593 96 g3 this is the reverse
dragon I've had a lot of games in this
game and usually with good results
Knight b6 and here comes a move which
probably and I was expected to be a
surprise for me but I already knew this
move and I had an idea where probably
black and get like a decent play so this
is like a rare scheme with III the most
usual like Knight f3 Castle then a 3 B 4
or like Knight f3 Castle d3 Bishop e3
like solid play so you had the reverse
dragon and you have an extra temple
which does not mean that you have an
advantage now in many schemes you can
play the move reverse colors but the
extra tempo just gives you a lot of
flexibility but does not mean that it
gives you like an advantage because it
should be very easy if this was true so
III 96 92 and here what I knew before
this game and that's why I played my
deal with g6 because it's kind of felt
like addition life for me I kind of felt
that the following patient which
occurred in this game will give me like
a very decent girl field g6 I just try
to finish development well it's not easy
to prevent black to finish development
like if you try to be a little bit
tricky a little bitty to reminds you
online of the of the pen of attack so
when you try to publish Bungie say oh no
they want to put bishop on a tree but of
course it's very
to prevent that so you play a five you
can even play first Bishop g7 in 1085
but here you put night on before and
probably this position you don't have
any you know reasons to complain because
the pawns in the center really much more
vulnerable than some kind of asset which
we will see in this game also so the
only move which a little bit toward me
is when they play strictly for equality
so d4 betrayed when you are with black
you have to accept a certain option so
you can get like an advantage out of the
opening
so d4 really does not give a white
everything but at least it can give them
a very equal position so if they take
just show you one line let's say with
the Queen here why why we play here c6
well because if I you know take for
granted at okay everything is fine I
play Bishop g7 night b5 no not very
pleasant so you have to take into
account the open adoptions to play c6
and he can play d5 in exchange a lot of
material here although this position
should not be any problem for public no
because the bishop on g7 compensate the
visual different the potato his race
case seems like a very Jewish position
to be honest but not a job so it can be
played but it seems unequal one well he
played caso Bishop g7 and now he plays
what is expected now why he can play d4
he plays f4 and this was the patient I
was aiming for you didn't get a feeling
it's it's kind of a quite a satisfactory
grow field for black I haven't played
much beautiful so Google is one of the
openings which was not really into my
upper tower with black although I repeat
I have played almost all of the openings
even the Kings Indian a couple of times
the Dutch even with some a very
interesting victories but I grew food I
get one curious game with a generational
mass in which in the sharp line with
Knight f3 in a ruby one where I had good
victories even from my youngest younger
years with white I just pushed my a pawn
to the whole game was I was pushing my a
pawn and reach a a 20
so this was like a rather curious game
so this was a good memory from
Bloomfield but really not much of a
experience so for me snap it was not so
easy to play a global picture but I had
a feeling it this is a good one well
during this game you see that the major
problem of me playing this game was that
you have a lot of good options and it
has to do with one weakness which I had
almost doing the whole chess career and
you try to work on your weaknesses but
they may will go away completely and
from time to time they appear again so
one of these weak spots was when you
have like three four good options which
really does not have much of difference
between them
so not that for example in one of the
options who you in material in one of
the other options you have like
completion advantage no they are very
similar then I tend to use more time
which is not very typical because rarely
I am in time trouble this is one of the
games in which there was like a kind of
a time trouble which really influenced
the game but here I spent a lot of time
now I'll show you the moment so 96 and
my opponent played quite dubiously not
only the the middle game face but I had
and I mentioned this in the kilometer I
had real problems to get his most almost
all of his moves were a surprise for me
so this happens sometimes
so here for example h3 in which he
played in my opinion looked like lots of
time it seems more natural to play
Knight afro because it is you try to
react against Queen e7 and e8 at least
you try to control more squares well I
still can't play like 97 to rearrange my
pieces but okay this is a backward moves
you have to also tune this time which is
something you really like to do it you
know in faster speed so okay even
visually right now has more active
pieces well I still can rearrange my PC
I gave you like couple of lines just
have an idea like for example this is
followed by c5 so you have problems in
in this patient basically with the
bishop on c1 so the bishop on Zito is
good but the other bishop suffers from
the situation of this puzzle on e3 and
e4 and this is like a real strategic
problem
if you just try for us to play 94 who
goes into the open file we should be to
Bishop d7 now 95 here just show you one
idea it's not possible because of the
trick Knight takes on d4 there's a small
technical trick which helps and after
Bishop takes from d4 the night is is
hanging or for example if you play
Knight f2 then the bishop goes to c6 and
although you down low your pawns now the
bishop on g2 has disappeared the bishop
on on d2 is really not like a great
piece and there is a lot of weak light
squares in your camp which compensates
the damaged power structure and of
course we have to add the B file so this
should be enough just to give you a
lines like let's say a root B 8 and now
the Queen does not have too many good
squares like if you play here c5 using
for example the the situation of the
bishop on on a detour because if you
take with a pawn the bishop is hanging
if you take with the rook Bishop f8 or
if you just captures just if he captures
the pawn on c6 well I keep playing it
and this move rook g6 then I can play
Bishop takes on d4 still not a complex
tactical shot but after I take with a
knight and I take the rookin c6 again
the bishop on on d2 is hanging no so but
still Knight f4 is clearly a better move
so h3 does not feel like you know it's
needed so a5 quite a natural move a fall
and all I also played a rather natural
move quite quite quickly which in many
occasions is a good sign also you have
to not to invest time where it's
strictly not needed probably it was a
little bit better to play to start with
queenie 7 because in some lines it gives
you more flexibility just to show you
this lines like if you place a 4 here
you can start immediately attacking his
center with c6 which is much into the
groin field spirit now in the spirit of
this defense so probably this was more
flexible
I played night before because kind of a
felt like a next
move king h2 queen e7 and OPA well this
all of these moves seemed quite natural
to me so I didn't look much into here it
was possible like c5 and to play for
dark square blockade know it seems
definitely looks better for black
valiant pay matters I thought that the
rookin d8 is a good square I'm not sure
if I'm right but you can look at all the
possibilities No so Queen b3 c5 this was
my intention now well heat it's quite
different the approach of a engine in a
human I thought that c5 because okay
then you get a lot of squares for your
pieces and if he plays d5 you have d5
square and you can put C for the knight
can go to DT well there is one piece
which you have to think about it is the
knight on basics so away you can't get
everything so night on b6 he's a little
bit off side so he has to go to but I
thought maybe 97 95 so I was quite happy
with the patient well the engine
approaches this patient differently but
it includes a move which I didn't even
look at it
so when I talk about this patient I
thought okay if I played c6 which the
computers like in Bishop III
well now the knight on basics gives him
additional motive so this is where I
stopped but the engine continues playing
a move which even if I see over the
broad I will not be very you know keen
to play and his ideas of course always
includes some tactical shots like here
taken d5 and at the end yeah totally I
mean during a during a chess game you
don't look so fresh so we you have to be
realistic you can look at at such lies
if you look at c6 you know and you see
Bishop e3 and you have to play rock a6
I'm not very happy about it so ok this
is like a different kind of a look at
the game so the computers have given us
more options but also we this is my
opinion we can plague like like
computers so c5 and of course if he
takes on c5 well then all of your pieces
then you
don't have to worry about the night on
v6 know the night in b6 well here of
course your stands as great because his
King isn't bad but if it takes on CV on
c5 then all of your pieces go into play
so of course he plays d5 and now I have
some memory that I thought quite a few
minutes here on the next move because
you have too many good options and maybe
I played a move which is too subtle so I
started to you know to play a little bit
too smartly I don't know if this is like
a right turn but the natural move here
should be like c4 and just to get your
PC to active Square but I kind of felt
okay the night on b6 maybe you know I
still have to put on a better position
so I was not satisfied although I didn't
have reason so here black should have a
rather good positioning all the lines
and no need to show the lines they are
having a very active position so only
one piece still needs to be redeployed
but it's not like a big problem so I've
kind of get a little bit greedy at that
okay I'll play Bishop d7 here I really
expected Bishop e3 and then 98 and my
last piece we'll get to a good square
well not immediately because the pollens
if I put okay it will go after some time
to d6 and it leaves all of my pieces
well plays maybe it was needed to play
more dynamically and of course even here
you can play like first c4 a 98 but I
don't like to give you know that's the
default square I don't like to give
their opponents you know my options so
really this may be good for an engine
but I don't like it so I prefer without
doing the move key for I prefer not to
include this move because it gives you
no access to squares which really makes
his play easier and what you want doing
a chess game is exactly the opposite and
you won't be open to have difficult
decisions or if you have easy decisions
that it has to be efficient when it
doesn't matter because okay he can have
a easy decision to resign or to play a
losing position there and I'm final with
it but away in a complication I don't
him to have like easy decision because
he saves time
in a way he feels more confident no so
h4 well this was a surprise to me
because hey like a few moves ago he
played H tweaking H 2 now H 4 well the
idea is obvious Bishop g5 but he's
weakening the G 4 square and Bishop g5
does not really make suspicion better so
I kind of you know start a little bit
and maybe to lose a little bit of focus
because I he was playing moves which
almost all of them I never expected and
after I played for example Bishop g5 and
you play let's say f6 which you can play
in many other ways then he he can go to
e3 because in most of the lines this
Bishop can be hanging so he has to go
back so that's why I really kind of a
start losing idea of what he wants to do
and here I paid CFO although Rukia
seemed quite natural move now here
Bishop e5 in basically you control most
of the important squares and it's not
good for him in his place for now so an
access to the square g4 is an additional
bonus so this was okay but okay I played
c4 Quinte one Bishop g4 well this was
also a move which seems very natural he
pulled another piece on a good square
pin his Knight Oh neato but I had doubts
I mean there were a lot of good options
even if just to give you an idea how
good this black patient you can even
sacrifice an exchange here which I
didn't have an intention to do because
when I have a good pushin no need you
know to pretend that you're more fee
even this patient the dark squared
Bishop you have like an extra Bishop in
an extra control type square gives you a
very good play probably the most
practical will just to play look okay
after Bishop g4 to play rocky 8 is their
Bishop g4 and you put all of your pieces
on good squares something like that know
exactly what you wanted to do but still
you know the the attraction of putting a
bishop on g4 also it's not too difficult
to understand because the bishop on g4
is a very active piece no sorry I played
Bishop g4 and I was really not too
worried about what what followed because
I couldn't believe that this is good
then
objectively it's not very good so Bishop
g5 f6 now you can go to e3 no that's why
I included c4 because then I take on d5
in the bishop is hanging so he plays
Bishop g5 f6 and now he plays Bishop c1
well if this is good then everything you
know you play over the chessboard can be
considered too interesting so I thought
that this is like a very good position
for black the only thing is how you
rearrange your pieces so you can start
immediately with an item b6 plate on d7
who can change but you don't have
something can create no so I started
with putting the knight on d3 still
keeping the bishop on on c1 and giving
you giving yourself a little bit more
options so sometimes even tonight on d3
he's very powerful sometimes you can
exchange it on so you want to transform
your advantage to give maybe a good
access to the two dark squares so that's
why I thought it 93 is a more a better
choice so he plays queen Seto
I played 97 now here of course I could
have exchange immediately and played
here but it gives him you know some
squares for the pieces and it gives him
and the knight on d3 what's preventing
that so okay it's there that I play
first 97 so no need to take the
responsive and of course Bishop e3 ok
and here just to give you an idea how I
think doing gee I never considered such
a line I don't know but I kind of feel
it's not not illogical to play something
like that and to give him some natural
moves no take take rook e1 so suddenly
all of key speeds which were quite
passive come into play so this is now
not my idea of how chest should be
played so I put D on i-25 so basically
all of my piece on active square the
bishop on g7 is temporarily a little bit
passive but array
still it has a good future now at least
it felt like that so 94 rook c8 and now
our surprise so I thought not he played
Bishop h3 but I thought it here he
should play something like 95 or okay
here Queen d7 I have control over the
boat I really didn't see what he can do
but this I also don't have something
like Emir some concrete I have just
visually very good position but all
right there is much work to do so there
is not like like a concrete immediate
plan when instead that he's giving me
exactly what I need he start weakening
his vision he plays Bishop h3 for some
very cheap tactical stuff and he forced
me to play some very easy move so Queen
d7 no of course to go back it means just
well you know to give an opponent idea
that you really don't know what are you
doing so he persists in his idea he
plays 96 Ruki 8 and now the patient
already in my opinion is quite bad
because when you've played Bishop 1896
there is no way back
for example if you take let's say 97 and
I take here you're without light squares
and preserving in the game yet promise
also on the light squares also on the
dark squares so especially when you try
to grab some material and your King is
quite vulnerable you can expect having
problems on one type of squares on maybe
on both type of square depending on the
position so he plays King g2 and now I
play this is really not and sacrifice
because it seemed so natural move that I
didn't spend any time on it I really
thought that here the position is with a
big advantage probably I even consider
it winning might hold ok this should be
played by by the hands it's quite
interesting that it didn't happen in the
game well there was like a slide time
trouble and it influenced some of the
following decision but still it's no no
excuse now now I'll show you because
there are a couple of very interesting
moment
so I played is very easy sacrifice
although it's not a real sacrifice here
because you take an exchange for a pole
and okay around kiss King I mean in the
bishop on g7 soon will be a B so and all
of your pieces knight on g4 Knight and
d3 I mean this is not a real sacrifice
bishop g1 and here
calculate the line and I told it this
line is winning and because I've
experienced it in my career when I work
on chess it if you see some line and you
really don't see why it should not work
you should follow you should believe in
ourselves and probably because of that
here a little bit out of emotions I
really played this line which is the
best the best and move every engine will
tell you but still it's a very
impractical decision that's why in my
opinion this is like a subjectively a
bad move so here black already head and
obvious in visually very easy to spot
positional advantage so they can just
play h5 you know just gaining from
control the right square they can pay
rookie eight they just feel oh this
complete operational moves and the white
pigeon is going to fall apart because
they don't have almost no square foot
for their pieces I can show you just a
few lines but although there is no need
for lines here many chests pace will
tell you that white justice problems all
over the broad they just cannot take
anything no because the Knights really
control everything or you can play like
rook e8 and still continue with your
plan but I saw a concrete line here and
I thought okay it's winning the problem
with the concrete lines when you have
some sort of a shadow of a time table or
a real time travel that depending of of
your strength and how you feel and when
especially you're in the end of your
career you may start seeing and it's
much more often in the end of you may
start seeing some kind of illusions on
me rise over the broad and then of
course very unpleasant things may happen
so here I played that five which I
thought that this is the end and it's a
very good move but it needs you know to
be sure yourself so okay here he doesn't
have a choice if he plays Queen took
Quincy six and okay I mean I don't see
how he can resist this position so he
takes on a five and here before taking
right fight because he had even less
time than than me it was not a real time
travel I saw that if he takes my five
the whole line which now see
you seems like winning for black but
when I get to this position aqui to
connect five with some kind of a making
some kind of a look that okay it's
alright for envoy I could have started
doubting and I started checking all over
and all over the life although now
you'll see it doesn't need to check them
so much because the the patient when I
had starting doubt is a little bit you
know too long so you have to just go to
estimate to evaluate the patient maybe
you are wrong but you have to you know
to trust your intuition so the line
where I started to head down was this
one instead of the move which I paid
very bad Queen six check this the first
line there is nothing better if he
covers then away this pin cannot be
sustained so check he has to play here
well the other line
no need you know to this was very easy
to spot no this so the line which I
started heading down was a frost line
this check Queen takes from a1 and now I
started having doubts not not on f6 I
told it 95 and I started you know
believing that my queen is offside that
Rosanna the patient is not clear and I
could have just trusted in my cells and
away you have enough material so you
need just one more to get the Queen back
and probably nothing will happen and if
I have trusted and just went into a
special all what about it was not
difficult to find a couple of decent
moves like hookah fate f6 in here these
are not only most he you can play with
even Bishop h6 but I kind of felt it ok
maybe it's dangerous
I didn't calculate enough disease
alliance after the game and of course
after the game I saw it okay it's and
you don't need to calculate many of this
line because I get the bishop on h2 is
not playing so there should be something
for black know so these are lines but
okay these are not difficult to spot
over the ball you just have to believe
that the position like this one when you
need just one tempo to get back your
queen and the material in this precise
position
just a clear exchange up and the bishop
is on h2 so it has to be winning so
there is no doubt about instead that I
starting you know thinking that maybe
it's giving him chances so ok let's
let's just take on a fight and I still
have stem of my initiative and here I
start missing things all the time anyway
having like a small time trouble and
having doubts this becomes like a real
time travel and you start missing really
important things so gtx 285 is a very
bad move because there was like a line
which has been calculated it was not a
difficult one and you just play against
yourself and it usually ends quite badly
so i take with a pawn he plays a very
simple move now of course check in here
he'll come with the queen so it does not
lead anywhere still it was better just
to play like 95 and something like that
but away this was too complex to play
after heck i have not entered into a
frost line which was much much easier so
instead of that i go into the endgame
which is not a bad one but still have to
play some good moves
so luke d1 and there comes the critical
mistake which loses the game but you are
witness that you know the real big
mistake was done much you know a couple
of moves before that because here you
start to lose faith in yourself so the
probability of making bigger mistakes
when probably i have here like five
minutes is becoming quite real because
you're already not sure of yourself
you've won one time you doubt it your
decision in a patient where you know it
was decided a couple moves because you
have to go to this vision and I of
course to an end game which I knew that
this end game probably blackest enough
for the exchange but nothing more in
here instead of Luka faded just
defending the poem which now may seem
national I thought okay I still have to
continue play actively so you are making
some kind of a transfer to what was
before when you had the initiative you
attacking to an endgame but already this
is not the same position so you can play
you know with the same notes at a time
better you know I have active pieces
because here the King does not have you
know the same kind of day
nothing like that and I just played a
kind of a blitz move brocade we just
misses a very simple tactic maybe not a
very simple technique but quite enough
for my opponent to see and after that it
was all downhill from from this moment
so he just taken high five
and it turns out if I take he plays King
f3 with a double attack and you just
exchange down no peace is not much peace
on the boat and the game a enters into a
technical phase which really was quite
unpleasant feeling no well here I try to
kick a little bit but still I'm sure on
the end of the game there was not much
to do so I play rock e5 he takes anyway
the rest of the game were just agony and
he didn't need my opponent with why I
didn't need to show some great technique
so I just tried to no looking for some
miracle to happen but away usually after
you've played like that they don't hit
and now you have two pieces for a route
but he spawns in the rookies to practice
and the king is super active so I mean
no chance at all not even a small
practical chance no so Roxy 596 well the
rest is really a very simple technical
position no and here I resigned because
of a the pawn just going he takes
everything so this was a rather
disappointing game for me by the way you
have to accept it okay it's not like it
it used to be so you start making more
mistakes after I played some some
interesting games and this was in the
fourth round of them and in the
penultimate round here tomatoes around
Robin 10 players I played against
grandma sneak off he was a he's a much
younger player which I've already played
three games against him I have won two
very good games an important ones and
also one he plays with with white I've
won one in the nimzo-indian
with Queen c2 a a very crushing game at
the other one I was in the person with
white also a crushing game and once in
the team championship we played
again Quincy to Indonesia which I have a
lot of experience with black and he paid
very salty it was a
unnormal draw so there was nothing much
happening so in this game I get you know
good memories also like like a diss
epona I've never have lost against him
so I guess Nicole I thought okay maybe
this is like a good chase to continue
the good results with him but it didn't
meant it was not meant to happen like
that
so let's see this game hello this game
also has some history which I sell so
when I started playing less and less I
was working in my main students for some
kind of really by lack they both were
playing the towers and okay you have to
adapt to the students who are coaching
so I start a lot and I've analyzed a lot
the tower so Oh even in the beginning I
shared with them that perish get some
kind of a handicap so there are a lot of
positions in the towers like at least
four to five vision when there are two
results on the broad I mean black have
to to do some kind of a miracle to have
winning chances and this is the kind of
mechanic of which in this opening has so
here in this game
I was really nothing climbed to play to
play tariff but before that I mean in
this tournament I've looked at some some
games he said I didn't see much of a
interesting light that he played with
with white against Irish and because
I've tried it a lot I said okay let
let's try the tariff although if I knew
that he is going to surprise me even on
the second move how have played the the
counter gambit Arbonne I played in the
second round against kilo George if I've
loved this game but still it was not
like a better opening position but after
d4 d5 I didn't want to go now for the
ninja because okay now I wanted to
experiment like in the last plant that
I'm at like a kind of a new openings
although Dallas was never happy opening
for me it it brought me a very important
victory in one of the tournament 2012
but it was mainly his opening surprise
and and then white went into a patient
is very complex with three results well
this game was completely different so
here my opponent played c4
well I cannot prepare to play a guest
came up in the counter gambit Albin let
me show you is c4 e5 well it's not very
solid and it's not completely correct we
have to be honest so I finalized it a
lot with my students just to give them a
little bit feeling for a sharper play I
used to look at more than ideas and I
developed some of them I have a lot of
interesting analysis but because Nikolas
was playing in this tournament always
Knight f3 so that's why I never expected
that he'll played c4 here so I never
prepared to play counter gambit
I've been against him but he played c4
which now gives him Marx has two
different two different trust kings
although I have to keep with my my
decision to play to rush and he goes
into one of the major lies well there
are couple of like three or four lines
where you can trust me that black always
have to to suffer at least the best I
can get is slightly inferior position
with like 20 or 30 moves guaranteed
suffering so that's why I don't like
really this opening but he goes here for
details on c5 Bishop c5 a three this is
one of the most modern lines black
always has some problems and I mean such
probably they started to play Knight e4
this gambit which if you accept the
sacrifice pawn on d5 gives you some
computation endgame or if you play
Quincy c2
it's kind of a ghetto slightly inferior
pigeon but you're holding you're not of
course this kind of opening play with 94
it was never to my liking so when I
analyzed this modern a tree with this
deal you know to fianchetto his bishop
on between most of the lines but with a
you know with gaining more space or not
we'd be tree but we ate read before
because space is very important in
chests so when I look at this I told it
the idea which I found was giving black
a satisfactory play so I analyzed
through key aid before Bishop betrayed
this was played and here the idea which
I found was
Bishop Beto to play a Bishop g4 in the
main idea just to show you the idea was
this one to exchange the LightSquared
Bishop which is quite unusual and using
the the b4 to sacrifice a pawn on b5 95
also the same could can be plain if he
doesn't include Brooke Chuang well no
need to go into into heavy analysis but
this was a rather interesting era I
wanted to try it now it was surprised
for me that Nicole played the whole line
and he didn't went for for Bishop Beto
he went for Bishop g5 which as far as
you knew was not like a dangerous move
so after I saw a Bishop g5 and here's to
think in the opening I played Bishop e6
and just don't think it I came he
provided I've looked at this patient and
I never saw like a dangerous line just a
couple of nine years if you pay c3 it
means that this Bishop has to be
exchanged
so Bishop e7 h6 and the bishop has to be
exchanged if your place looks you want
the same
okay I think if you place 94 you play a
six and then he doesn't have like a very
good square for this Bishop for example
if it goes back let's say here if he
patiently exists you take with a pawn no
because it makes your your pawn Center
much healthier and a good one now you
take and now of course you use the fact
that he has played Adrian before so you
have access to c4 and this is good for
you and if he takes one f6
this is solid option but I didn't see
some of your problems so the pushin
looks like an equal 100 key one okay
well it's also a very dry one so you
also get can witness some of the
handicaps of the of the parish but okay
I mean sometimes you play what you have
from the ball well my opponent here
taught for over 30 minutes and you know
sometimes you get some kind of like a
fate revenge or something because I
remember many many years ago this has
not been true it in this command like at
least thirty years before this game
there was a game in the in the dragon in
the fianchetto Dragon that when a black
plays a dragon and
white played the patient of scheming
with g3 Bishop g2 so there was a game
between
toshko feet wide isabelle campus and Sam
Cooke who is international Mastan was an
editor of my check Musa a good friend of
mine so there was an idea in depression
online of the fianchetto with Bishop g2
they play 95 white they pay ok - with
idea then to play B 3 and C 4 so this
rookie - was playing this game Tosk of
Sam Cooke high dose cough is not invent
this idea he has seen it in some Russian
game I think and the command I still
remember it and I was having a very good
laugh so the comment of some of my
friends was well this rookie - it felt
all all the same consumers if atomic
bombing is probably over his head so I
was laughing because I was imagining his
same girlfriend is you know something
like that happening and I was laughing
it's a it's very funny what are they
after many many years I get a very good
luck
you know forget the same of playing
against me with almost the same crushing
impact so here after 30 minutes house
walking and I was quite you know alright
with the opening position I came over
the bottom I saw ok - going under the
bishop musics well I need it like
between 5 5 to 7 minutes to understand
that this is a very unpleasant move and
not only unpleasant I understood most
depletion especially the Thai fusion I
didn't want to have in this opening just
there is tours out from the broad and
there is like an eternal suffering in
front of you so the move has a very
clear idea it wants to go to D - also it
defends the the second-ranked so now you
have to to consider Bishop f6 in 95 with
a clear exit poll and just actually what
what you are going to do about that
well I thought thought and even I get
like this was played like in the 17 of
May a couple of days after that I was
even when I go to stay by I was still
thinking about it what did I do wrong
care I could done something better but
still until this day I haven't found
well I think this is like a great
opening Note II and basically cancels
out this whole line for for black so it
it can be played if you want to suffer
now
but this is not like something I really
enjoy
so here the basic idea if he pays bishop
ezel he plays through b2 and now he just
takes the pawn and okay you can pretend
here that you have some kind of
compensation here I even gave him I
commanded before going to sleep a couple
of days ago I wanted to make this you
know work to make this patient to have
some compensation but still you know
after spending some time it's not really
working exactly if you play like d4
he plays rube the tool and just takes
the pawn and still you know no real
compensation for for the pond so instead
of giving our material right beside it
okay and take into account the ruku nato
basically what happened again as we play
rock yet he plays Bishop on f6 so if I
take if I take on on f6 with a queen 95
so the pawn on only two is defend it now
this is a rather important movie
something which I have not included but
let me show you at the boat so if you
take with the Queen let's say I can take
here and you have an extra pawn okay you
can try to play for some chick tricks
probably here you can take Bishop takes
here even if I take on b4 play Queen b3
integral I'm in my opinion clearly
better but I can even play here Queen b3
and there are take on b7 oh so I keep
having an extra pawn and still the
different piece on the board the
different kind of bishops make this
touch even more unpleasant because he is
going to play on the squares where you
don't have you know natural defenders so
it makes your patient worse it's not
he's not getting it but if it was in one
flank
well maybe you can hold on but when you
have portion on both lengths it's really
difficult ero equality of course it was
like very painful for my school to look
at my pawn structure in the whole game
is a very good example how important is
the pawn structure in chess so I took
here with the pawn but already I knew
that this person is is very unpleasant
ninety-five still here I want to play a
5 but somehow I felt that it's too
like a difficult position so after
analyzed after game and during the game
I didn't believe it it's enough it's
quite curiosity when I look at this game
like maybe more than two years after it
was played so this was like the last
game in this line enough to use somebody
adventure to play it again
and of course it's gettin bad like so
here they tried a five which seems like
a better moment basically the difference
is not much you are still left with a
bad bone structure and with a clear
positional problem so after a five take
94 I think I can even find the game
which was played because I think that
it's a rather instructive and I don't
know why they went into this pigeon
because this pigeon is is clearly a
difficult one to play no he has a very
solid bone structure and can have a lot
of weak spots to attack you know all of
your pawns are like you know potential
targets
h7 f6 f7 d5 this is like you know some
kind of a fruits which are waiting to be
to be gathered no so the game which I
found in 2060 in the last game this line
was rook g3 a4 route C for a3 route Cade
and now of course he starts you know
attacking your pawns anyway here
positionally he should be lost
he they won't the game quite easily Ruby
I don't remember they played here in the
back I didn't gave here the whole game
but he already the patient is very bad
no I mean he's attacking the pawn b7 and
what can I do about it is a he's a
mystery no meanwhile there's even a
double techno on the pawn on f6 well I
decided nothing wrote a 5 just to wait
for a better moment the way still it
does not help much into the position now
so Queen b6 94 now you can play a 5 so
you can play this in many occasions but
still enough left material on both
flanks so it will be you'll be happy if
you get something which really is not
easy to achieve so you can get exchanged
like the a lot of pieces and get
exchange these defy
in p7 for the poor on a3 and you know
get some kind of a position on well
think maybe you can hold it on but you
know this is not easy to see how how is
going to happen because for Kim is much
easier to attack on the on the B line
and on the on the light squares the pawn
on d5 then you can get access to his
pawns no and it's not really clear how
it's going to happen so here even if you
play a five he still gets his position
and his pcs on a on a very natural
natural squares and then Ruby well and
because of the very terrible pawn
structure you have you basically have to
sit in and - look how improves his
position it's not so taking your in one
of the basic advantage of suspicion he
decides when he wants to change
something what if you want to change the
pawn structure because it's so damaged
for you that you know and he can take
only six whenever it's advantageous for
you or you put the pot on a four so it's
very difficult we don't touch any of
these pawns
so I played here Bishop g7 because I
thought at least I can include my Bishop
with f5 and try not to get like more
chances to have a defense position with
chances tool to defend but after Bishop
g7 III I started to make okay when you
have this kind of a problem equation in
your opponent plays quite well you start
you know feeling the pressure so you
start making not not always but when you
are not in your best form you start
making some small concession here
initially I paid which would be saying
because I wanted to follow it at five
but then when it happened over the boat
I was not very happy about Knight takes
me six and this what I meant that he can
change the pawn structure because his
contract is much better whenever he
wants this third time the advantage of
having a good pawn structure
so here in taken e6 anyway it seems like
good for you
but then he placed 95 and now I couldn't
see how do you react on the threat
Knight takes really six which seems very
unpleasant well it's not the only threat
he can also go Queen h5 but suddenly the
light squares which is not a big
surprise because let's let's face you
don't have a light square Bishop becomes
a real issue for now so I couldn't see
what can I do here so I didn't pay a
five so I wait here all the time I have
this very difficult choice which of many
evils I have to to prefer a No
so this was a rather difficult game to
play my opponent plays very well so this
is this is true so 94 it was not too
difficult because when you have like
clearly defined targets in the enemy
camp it's not too difficult it was much
more difficult the game for me know than
for my opponent the f5 rule dito
logically he keeps the control a 5 and
now a very good move he doesn't give you
any time so just keeps the necessary
material so instead of you know taking
away 5 no he just paid queen h5 very
good move I take on before any place
would be one so you have exchanged some
pieces but still your weak spots
continue so it's very possible that in
some near future maybe not so near but
quite enough your pawns on f5 d5 and b7
disappear huh
which you know will change a lot you
know you're feeling about the position
so it's not easy to imagine what really
you can exchange to make your position
better and he can choose whenever you
start picking up here the pairs let's
let's call them all the airport's so
here I played Luke t1 probably because I
am me some tactical detail
I wanted to play Bishop d4 but after you
looked again at this line which kind of
a ferret ok I can exchange our it's
still you know you could make the
variation work but ok this this is
probably quite logical because your
pollution positionally is not sound I
mean you have too many weak spots so
here this was my first intention but
still you know even when on the bottle
left heavy pieces you still have you
know bad King bad pawns
now you can I mean if you take a dive
architects with a pawn everything is
hanging hits now
as an extra pass pawn very very bad
choice so instead of that
I pay truck Chauhan no it's not really a
tactic but you're trying a little bit to
confuse him but he kept his line
look patience here take root d1 no
everything is under control
and here I made a mistake which probably
didn't influence the result of the game
but you know you start getting tired and
after calculating lines and always you
know seeing a pigeon which is quite
uncomfortable and you know that it's a
bad position so instead of playing Queen
before honey at least you know defending
the power on b7 although I don't like
here not night advice no after 95 at
least you can push d4 here you have some
serious scoffs like impression like that
well the end game will be perfect no the
opposite called Bishop not much material
well this of course can be saved but
what I didn't like is like we already
mentioned the possibility to change the
pawn structure whenever he feels like
that so here he can take 96 something
which in the previous in the line I
faced in the game I just after
calculating off like I just forgot about
this possibility this is the truth so
after I paint Queens two eyes for good
he can take
Knight takes Rooney six and you can take
with a pole very important because the
rock is hanging no so you have to be
left with all the support from the light
square so he doesn't have to reach very
further no just with the bishop
collecting all of them no it don't have
to be tired no so 96
Ruki six Bishop d5 and all right this
also in my opinion should be a lost
position right but at least you have the
power of b7o at least you know you can
put more fight you can pretend that not
everything is clear although this should
be technically and also a lost position
in my opinion but I played Queen c3 just
really forgetting about Knight 926 and I
get the same position with a slight ball
that missing the pawn on B cell well now
it's very easy you know and the rest was
a quite easy technical task how I'll
give you the game with your Timon
because all of the game - then I even
don't remember because it was like
really in a
situation here he just kept picking up
upon on every five moves now so he just
plays on the on the light squares if
keys on the piano here before I was
hoping for some kind of a miracle but
away it didn't happen and now we play
with two extra pawns and he can always
you know attack me on the light squares
and in one moment he start pushing the
pawns and you know when the pawns go to
a four or a five and away after that he
has like the bishop here and on the
light squares you don't have any space
so oh yeah here I could not included the
rest of the game but I can assure you
that it was not probably because I
didn't kept it on the on the score sheet
but it was not difficult so just put his
piece on the last square started putting
the poem in one Mon therefore F 4 e 5
and away you can sustain the prison
because the your king is weak and almost
all of the end games a loss like the
Queen endgame is lost and you can have
like the the bishop ending no okay this
will be a dream but it can happen no
because you can exchange the Queen's in
such a he just have to be careful about
only one detail just not to exchange the
quiz and to have some kind of a drawing
changes because at least there you know
exist the changes because this Bishop
you know the colonies is dark so UK by
the way it never happened so this was a
rather unpleasant loss but I have to
give the credit to my opponent who
created very good opening idea and play
the whole game
strictly positional and very good so
wait one thing I just have to read at
least the last game the night game I
wanted at least you know the last game
gave me a little bit better taste in the
mouth but okay this one was really
unpleasant so thank you very much and I
hope to continue with this bittersweet
memories in the next occasions thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]